what would you say if i told you that
everything you've been taught about a
healthy diet has been a lot
well maybe it's not that bad but between
nutritional research lobbyist groups and
outdated science some really poor eating
choices have been recommended let's look
at how they've confused us and examine
what we really should be eating thanks
to omar plus for sponsoring this video
the united states first implemented
dietary guidance in 1894 and it changed
constantly because of things like the
depression world war rationing and a
discovery of vitamins and minerals
things didn't get firmly established
till 1956 when the usda announced the
dietary guidance known as the four basic
food groups this became the main
education tool for american school
children for the next 36 years so what
were they pushing people to eat if there
are four basic food groups as they said
in 1956 what do you think those four
basic food groups are proteins poultry
vegetables dessert
protein vegetables fruit protein and
fruits ah that's not right steak
chicken eggs how about those fruits and
vegetables man the four basic food
groups were as follows milk meats fruits
and vegetables and grains these foods
were introduced as part of a balanced
meal and the recommendation was that you
eat all of these foods every single day
however these recommendations had major
flaws for example there was no
distinction made between refined grains
like white bread and whole grains like
whole wheat bread and it's an important
one to make because whole wheat bread
takes more energy for your body to break
it down therefore it doesn't spike your
blood sugar it doesn't spike your
insulin these are really important
factors that affect the metabolic state
within your body the worst part of this
guidance is that it provided no guidance
for the proportions of how much you
should be eating in fact in a single day
you could have a well-balanced meal with
a gallon of milk a ribeye steak peanut
butter and jelly sandwich on white bread
and a single piece of broccoli i don't
think that's so healthy and kind of
weird well things then got better
sort of over the years the usda had
realized there should be a bit more
nuance in how people eat so they
introduced the idea of proportionality a
great move unfortunately the usda often
relied on industry experts to help craft
and improve official dietary guidance
this influence from groups like the
dairy corn and meat industry led to
dramatic messaging surrounding the
importance of things like low fat or
fat-free foods with zero recognition of
the benefits of things like healthy fats
and clean oils but while they suggested
eating different proportions of foods
they didn't necessarily recommend the
right proportions bread pasta cereal
oatmeal carbs on carbs on carbs the
bottom of this food pyramid is literally
all grains and its recommendations were
6 to 11 servings a day there's only 10
servings of oatmeal in here look how
much it is i mean look i'm not here to
demonize a single food ingredient
because whole grains could totally be
part of a healthy diet the problem here
is if you look at their recommendations
and proportions you could literally be
eating twice as much white bread as you
do vegetables a day and it was
permissible and recommended by this food
pyramid that's poor guidance also
america was going through its fat-free
low-fat kick which meant that we were
demonizing fats not all fats are bad a
and b we also poorly understand fats
like do you know the difference between
whole milk and one percent this is two
percent milk what does the two percent
number represent two percent of
how much dairy is in it two percent
lactate two percent reduced
fat fat the percent of fat in there
exactly so it's the percent of fat by
weight this is whole milk what percent
is in whole milk just all the fat all of
it a hundred percent probably zero you
think this has less fat than the two
percent yes ten percent eighty percent
eighty percent hundred percent one
percent fifty percent forty
four hundred
percent forty forty percent three or
four percent you're right that's really
how did you know i'm just guessing and
for getting milk for a second once you
remove fat food begins to taste pretty
badly so what do we do through a ton of
sugar in there what did that do spike
our insulin spike our blood sugar make
our waistlines get bigger and here we
are right in the middle of an obesity
epidemic
despite the flaws and nutritional
guidance over the years there has always
been a strong push for variety in your
diet which is exactly what you can find
with a walmart plus membership you see
walmart plus membership gives you free
same-day delivery of fresh groceries
from your local store they've got high
quality ingredients for your everyday
cooking like organic fruits vegetables
primed beef organic chicken and so much
more with a walmart plus membership
prices are the same as they are on the
shelf there are no markups which means
that you get the same high quality fresh
food you expect from walmart at the most
reasonable prices and because of these
low prices walmart plus is perfect for
everything from weekly meal planning to
prepping seasonal dishes and believe me
the selection is excellent offering
fresh seasonal fruit like these mangoes
pineapples cherries and even seedless
watermelon once you place an order
specialty trained shoppers hand pick the
freshest items like they're shopping for
their own families strawberries are
picked the day of the delivery not
before and you could really taste that
difference they don't just do fresh food
products though they also deliver what
you need for your home for your family
like paper towels beauty products and
even back to school supplies look when i
tell my patients about the benefits of a
well-rounded diet i often hear their
struggles of rising costs of fresh foods
and i get it but one of the best parts
of having a walmart plus membership
offering high quality foods fresh
products at reasonable prices and all
without hidden fees to me it's a win so
click the link below to start your free
trial now in 2005 they came out with
some better nutritional guidance and
they gave us a pyramid to look at what
do you take away from it oh there's like
different categories of foods
i don't know what i'm supposed to be
saying right now though does it tell you
how much of each food you should eat no
it's confusing
it seems like the further he gets up the
less he eats i don't really get it get
to the top try to eat all of them this
is the steps he needs to take in his
diet to reach the top
nope now the good part is my pyramid
does aim to provide some insight into
proportionality as represented by these
colorful stripes on the pyramid but it
stops there leaving you to estimate how
much more orange there is than yellow
it's really really confusing the chaos
of the my pyramid wasn't a total waste
though because there was a wide variety
of foods here unlike the four basic food
groups there was upwards of 40 different
foods on the graphic in 2011 the
government tossed all the confusing
guidance from the pyramid into the trash
and introduced us the new redesigned my
plate it was going to change how we
talked and communicated about nutrition
unfortunately they may have over
corrected while the misguided
proportions of the pyramids were now
gone they also pulled a complete 180 in
regards to fitness where'd the stairs go
we've also introduced a new word into
our graphic protein and while
recognizing that protein comes in forms
that extend beyond animal products is no
doubt an important evolution in
messaging there is but one fatal flaw
protein is a macronutrient not a food
group this means that you can get your
protein portion with hamburgers and hot
dogs yeah tasty but not an ideal healthy
source of protein there is something i
love about my plate fish for the first
time we actually see guidance
recommending the consumption of seafood
and it's such a healthy food it contains
omega-3 fatty acids we've actually seen
evidence of reductions in heart disease
and stroke risk my biggest issue with my
plate is that it says a hundred percent
fruit juice is the equivalent of a fruit
serving yeah maybe the vitamins and
minerals are in there but do you know
how much sugar is in here a can of cola
a popular energy drink some sugar cubes
fruit juice which one of these four has
the most sugar i would say the energy
drink maybe probably the can of soda and
it is drink why do you say that because
i drink energy drink every day to do my
job
and it gives you that sugar kick yeah
energy drink the soda what if i was to
tell you those two have the lowest
amount of sugar
how are the pure sugar cubes no no no
the fruit juice you're right i am and i
actually sometimes drink it thinking
that it's more nutrition yes fruits
contain sugar but they also contain
fiber which slows the absorption of the
sugar thereby not spiking your blood
sugar not spiking your insulin drinking
100 fruit juice might get you the
vitamins and minerals but it's also
gonna spike your sugar just like any
other unhealthy sugary beverage folks
just eat the fruit in strong contrast to
the pasta extravaganza from 1992 we
finally see vegetables dominating the
plate while this is excellent to see the
further guidance doesn't differentiate
between leafy dark green vegetables and
potatoes as much as it breaks my heart
to say so potatoes and french fries do
not count as your daily vegetable and
that brings us to what modern
nutritional guidance is today what
should you be eating what should i be
eating for that we turn to our friends
at harvard back to the kitchen here's a
plate of food recommended by harvard's
modern nutritional guidance we're
entirely removing dairy and swapping it
out for a healthy fat like olive oil but
it's nice that we're finally making the
statement that not all fats equal bad
because there are healthy fats and they
play important roles within your body
creating hormones protecting your organs
giving you energy and even boosting your
hdl which is your good cholesterol for
the record there's nothing wrong with
having dairy remember we're not
villainizing ingredients it's about not
having excess dairy and not having low
quality dairy another great addition to
their recommendations is good
old-fashioned water it's important to
stay hydrated not only for you to feel
healthy but also to encourage your
metabolic rate those who are dehydrated
actually have trouble losing weight and
have lower levels of energy also as you
notice the majority of the plate is
plant-based fruits and vegetables but
it's really important to get a wide
variety of vegetables in different
shapes colors and even sizes their focus
on healthier proteins like fish chicken
beans and nuts is also really sharp
because these are all yummy options that
carry a lot of vitamins and minerals and
finally we get some guidance that
encourages you to eat whole grains
rather than refined ones i've actually
gone vegan and keto for 30 days and it
wasn't easy so click on those to check
it out and again huge thank you to
walmart plus for sponsoring this video
click the link in the description to
start your free trial today stay happy
and healthy
[Applause]